hola que tal un cordial saludo a todas y
todos y bueno les habla pablo gómez
barrios y es un placer estar con ustedes
hoy acá en este castor cibernético o
canadá en las américas café de el
viernes 8 de febrero en vivo y en
directo por facebook live youtube y en
nuestro sitio internet aquí en el
estudio luis laborda paloma martínez y
leonardo gimeno estamos para amenizar
este momento
ese es nuestra función de amenizar este
momento acá con nuestros internautas
allá del otro lado de la cámara y del
micrófono a quien saludamos que tal
bienvenidos a todos y luis laborda te
veo medio callado medio escéptico con
respecto a la amenizada del espectáculo
eso de amenizar bueno pues signo porque
presentar pues se puede presentar sin
amenizar también si manny cada quien se
arregla como le dé la gana lo que hacían
los astronautas y martín saban cuando
llegan marcan en alunizar van en la luz
la ceremonia y después cuando lleguen a
otros planetas ya veremos qué verbo
vamos a encontrar para ese se
estrellaban en la tierra que era
[Risas]
bueno un calurosos saludos a todas y
todos y como ven pues estamos aquí de
muy buen humor para pasar este rato con
ustedes y hablando de buen humor no sé
si ustedes tienen alguna nota que les
haya llamado la atención algo insólito o
una noticia en el vacación si en esta
ocasión cita lo más bueno ya me estaba
preguntando venía inquieto me decía
tendrá algo no
pues fíjate resulta que en sets il que
es una ciudad alejada en el noreste de
quebec
hay tanta nieve hay tantísima nieve que
ya han puesto los algunos letreros de
alto en las esquinas sobre los bancos de
nieve gigantescos tengo una foto para
acompañarlo pero no sé si leonardo la
pueda buscar para que se la vea nuestros
oyentes también si no no va a aparecer
muy bien mira leo este es el título que
dice la que dicen los de entre 2 abajo
de esta montaña y una casa que pare eso
es lo que dice el letrero pero ve yo te
muestra agregado de nosotros tanta nieve
y no se veían los letreros oficiales me
parece un poco
y lo que sucede es que hay tanta gente
que dio tanta nieve que la gente ya no
veía porque quedaba por abajo el letrero
ese de pare de alto entonces decidieron
sacar unos unos portátiles y lo puse
alguien pasa de largo y otro llega y
bueno de por si la gente no respeta
siempre los altos que están en las
esquinas y en invierno además aunque tú
quieras para eso entonces me pareció
gracioso porque son buenos cosas que uno
va desarrollando astucias digamos para
enfrentar el invierno el invierno
canadiense este invierno quebequense que
este año pues no está tratando muy bien
no sea muy bien en el sentido de que
tenemos la abundancia de nieve y
abundancia de estilos de
invierno en cada semana es una nueva
nueva aventura hay lluvia y nieve y
aguanieve hay todo en una semana están
anunciando tempera y mira estaba llovió
está negada a toda la ciudad de montreal
y anuncian mucho frío para esta noche
entonces eso se va a convertir en una
hermosa pista de patinaje de primavera e
invierno en la muy pegaditos en días
seguidos siete especies es cierto que
bueno ya habíamos visto inviernos así
como este pero me parece que es
particular este invierno
esos cambios tan bruscos y creo que es
porque habíamos visto inviernos que han
comenzado muy tarde habíamos visto
invierno se han comenzado muy temprano
bien habíamos visto invierno con
muchísima nieve invierno muy poca pero
no con variaciones tan abruptas como
aquí que un día llueve un día cae nieve
otro día que haya dos días en el sol
calor frío calor calor no exageremos
y yo vi gente con bermuda esta mañana
había gente corriendo en la mañana
haciendo ejercicio en bermudas por lo
menos yo no es que eso ese es el efecto
y mamadera justamente eso es lo que
dicen que va a pasar lo que va a ser más
calor en las zonas donde se fría sino
que la fluctuación va a ocurrir en mucho
menos tiempo o sea esto es por ejemplo
la lluvia helada y eso estamos
acostumbrados a fines de marzo cuando
empieza a cambiar a temperatura ya hemos
tenido lluvia helada en diciembre enero
estamos en febrero también la tenemos
o sea eso es el cambio climático no es
que vaya a ser más frío sino que las
condiciones van a cambiar de manera
rotunda en mucho menos tiempo
a mí lo que me sigue llamando la
atención sabes que es como se acostumbra
la gente al medio ambiente
el cual ha crecido porque yo hace ya
unos 15 años que vivo aquí y sigo sin
acostumbrarme a caminar sobre el hielo
si no me pongo los famosos clavos los
crampones que le decimos aquí en mi
calzado para ti no como nureyev en su
cerebro que ha tenido una mala
experiencia de caída con fractura esté
incluida y así que tengo un obsequio
metálico en una de las piernas y no eso
es cuando pasan los aeropuertos de
tejido tejido como para que como pero no
yo no logro acostumbrarme a caminar
sobre el hilo sino en pongo los clavos
de hecho y no me los puse y en un par de
momentos me vertical estuvo a punto de
perderse pero en bases de baile
veo a la gente que ha nacido y crecido
aquí camina sin clavos sin nada sobre el
hielo sin ningún problema y recuerdo
siempre la imagen de una muchacha en
gatineau donde yo vivía en las primeras
épocas aquí mías en canadá que salía con
con aguja en su departamento y caminaba
sin problemas o bien podríamos definir
de otra manera
[Risas]
hay que explicarle a nuestros oyentes
que cuando nos oyen hablar de esta forma
y de estas temperaturas que estamos y de
otros accesorios y de los accesorios que
utilizamos que cuando luis laborda habla
de estos clavos es que se vende acá en
invierno unos accesorios en la planta en
la suela del zapato se engancha en el
talón y tiene clavos en el talón en la
parte de abajo sobre el talón y en la
parte de delante justo antes de entregar
los dedos
entonces eso da mucha más posibilidad de
estabilidad cuando cuando se camina y
sobre todo cuando hay mucho hielo
entonces pues es necesaria finalmente en
este accesorio es necesario simplemente
fue lo que le pusimos a nuestras
bicicletas
clavitos hemos tenido que abandonar la
bicicleta tú y yo pero por otras razones
que no tienen que ver con la nieve pero
estábamos muy dispuestas tus sistemas
que yo mi bicicleta por la nieve
entonces y eso es clavitos se adhieren
digamos es una llanta especial que se
adhiere a la nieve de manera que no nos
valemos todo el tiempo y nos digamos que
no es que uno no se resbale se resbala
menos y hay que estar siempre muy atento
y tener mucho cuidado
la gente más dos participaciones ya en
nuestro en nuestro facebook en el primer
momento fue guild en abril que dice que
esa meta que significa amenizar amenizar
bueno amenizar para la la definición de
la real academia de la lengua no la sé
mientras que en ese entonces exacto
administrar que decir volver algo más
ameno y quiere decir más agradable más
convivial más simpático eso en fin esa
es la idea de amenizar se puede
administrar una fiesta se puede
administrar una reunión un programa de
radio
entonces si entramos acá en el estudio
con esa idea de amenizar eso es hacer
ameno un lugar o alguna otra cosa dice
la real academia de la lengua y yo lo
que no quiere decir si no no que tenga
otro mensaje activada antes de fm radio
j sólo éxitos dice estar dependiente
para verlos en vivo saludos a todos a
todo el equipo periodístico de rci en el
pasado nos escuchaba por onda corta a
las seis de la tarde -hora local-
colombia imagínate si es y bueno ya no
estamos en la no estamos en las ondas
cortas pero bueno estamos acá en
internet te tratando de de llevarles
este buen humor que reina aquí
estudios y palm entonces cómo eran las
cosas nada de eso era más divertida
algunas cosas y algo que les tuvo luis
laborda yo tengo algo que comentar pero
no sé si necesariamente agradable
tiene que ver con la noticia que hice
hoy que es una queja y un pedido de
investigación que se presentó en el
parlamento canadiense por un presunto
caso de discriminación que ocurrió en la
colina del parlamento allí en ottawa
días pasados hubo un evento que
involucró a representantes de la
comunidad negra en canadá que como
nosotros bien sabemos no sé si el
público en el exterior no lo sabe pero
aquí la población de color negro es muy
importante no es que hay poca gente de
color negro en este país es más estamos
en el mes de la negritud de la historia
de la modelo descargada vrae
sentidamente y en relación precisamente
una de la negritud se llevó a cabo un
evento en el parlamento canadiense en el
que estuvieron invitados varios
representantes de esa comunidad que
tenían previstas reuniones con
legisladores canadienses legisladores
y mientras estaban en una especie de
hall de entrada esperando que esas
realidades se concretasen un integrante
del cuerpo de seguridad del parlamento
les pidió que se retiraran y que
esperasen el evento al cual habían sido
convocados en la confitería del lugar a
caramba y todo esto a partir de una
queja de un funcionario gubernamental
que preguntó qué hacían estas personas
allí y a las que les sacó fotos sin
pedir ningún tipo de autorización
entonces hay algunos legisladores que
han presentado un pedido de
investigación para saber en qué
circunstancias y con qué razón se
procedió a desalojar a la gente que
contaba con la acreditación pertinente
para encontrarse en el lugar en el que
estaban y como uno de los dictadores
dijo el parlamento es una casa que
pertenece o perdón este espacio
pero ese a todos los canales necesarios
entonces todos tienen derecho de estar
allí y si hay lugares que son reservados
con la acreditación mediante que esta
gente tenía en su poder tenía el derecho
de permanecer ahora porque le llamó la
atención a este integrante del cuerpo de
seguridad que
personas estuviesen en un lugar y no
otras el presunto caso de discriminación
en parte también tiene que ver con el
hecho de que las instituciones
canadienses siguen siendo aún
instituciones en las que hay poca
presencia de las minorías visibles del
país entonces en el caso del parlamento
canadiense no es muy común ver a gente
de color negro de raza negra no se dice
de raza ya no existen las razas chino no
es aceptado creo que ya es la raza
humana únicamente es decir de piel negra
hay gente que no hay muy poca gente de
este color de piel en la institución
como tal entonces por supuesto que un
policía no está acostumbrado porque la
institución no ha tenido digamos una una
una aceptación de la diversidad por
razones históricas por razones políticas
por las que sean entonces las
instituciones canadienses siguen siendo
aún instituciones que representan a la
mayoría blanco
la francófona o anglófona del país que
creo que es una evidencia entonces
probablemente que con poca conciencia de
la de la realidad de la sociedad
canadiense de hoy este policía actuó
digamos con unos unas tendencias
inconscientes probablemente con unas
costumbres
peor que las malas costumbres para para
que se salgan de nuestro comportamiento
y también nos permite cuestionarnos con
respecto a eso porque hay varias varios
movimientos en canadá y el mes de la
historia 'la negra' es uno de los de los
momentos especiales en los que se habla
cada vez más de la presencia y la
importancia y la contribución de las
comunidades negras del país son
comunidades de muchos orígenes además
contribución de estas comunidades a la
historia canadiense a la vida canadiense
de hoy contemporánea entonces creo que
es un momento de reflexionar como nuevas
instituciones están concebidas y digamos
formadas no incluir los cambios que se
requieran o quiero agregar que en
nuestro sitio internet que ya están
viendo allí
a la derecha la pantalla tienen aquí
justamente a la derecha de la derecha
abajo de la población el centro de abajo
de la publicidad de la aplicación tienen
meses de la historia de la negritud en
canadá si ustedes hacen clic pueden
entrar allí y ver reportajes que tienen
que ver con esto que hablaba paloma y
bueno en este caso tiene que hacer que
las personalidades de la historia de la
negritud en canadá retratos personalidad
canadienses de origen negro y los
reportajes que nosotros realizamos
durante todo el año con respecto a esta
a ésta
[Música]
lo enriquecemos
durante todo el año pues todo lo que
vamos hablando que vamos trabajando
nosotros sobre ese tema se va agregando
a esa sección ese que hizo luis esta
mañana y uno que yo hice ayer justamente
porque la real en la casa de moneda real
de canadá decidió dedicarle honrar al
odio la desmonte que es una activista
hoy hoy murió pero es decir una
activista por los derechos de las
comunidades negras en el país de halifax
le dedica una moneda de plata especial
una moneda conmemorativa especial y un
billete
comenzó con el billete creo que se hizo
todo un concurso y todo lo demás para
elegir a la personalidad que iba a
representar a la comunidad negra en la
película el papel moneda canadiense y
fue ella de viola desmont que además es
la primera mujer en un billete
canadiense además de la película
en todos los billetes y en todas las
monedas de este país bueno tengo
comentarios en este caso decía guild en
abril dice son muy buenos profesores
gracias por explicación
manfred echeverría y saludos amigos
pendientes como todas las semanas en mi
segunda patria en canadá o canadá
empieza a cantar y después de javier
gonzález nunca hay presente desde
guadalajara méjico contra el 73 y un
abrazo a paloma luis pablo como barrios
y leonardo interesante el programa fm
radio j sólo éxitos dice saludos de
malambo norte de colombia madame pues es
en la costa norte en el departamento del
atlántico
ni idea
educativa de colombia y maría herrera
dice como siempre acá con ustedes un
saludo desde san luis argentina así que
agradecemos a todos aquellos que están
saludos a todos y muchas gracias por
estar por acompañarnos
coterráneo tuyo sí señor hemos trabajado
juntos en la universidad con me parecía
y bueno entonces ya todos hablaron de lo
insólito
yo no tengo hecho en su no tienes hecho
bueno yo tengo uno a quien fui curioso
lo compartimos con todos acá porque me
parece yo no sé de hecho antes de
comentarlo quiero pedirle a los que nos
están escuchando cómo es eso en sus
países respectivos no como ya ustedes
saben que acá ahora se está se puede
personalizar las placas de los carros
no hacer que sea de dentista
hay que tener que poner la profesión
malayo y uno que decía de ahí y me
imagino que era alguien de haití el que
en su placa está escrito de haití bueno
entonces eso es algo nuevo acá en canadá
y es caro y es caro hay que pagar para
porque son caras 350 dólares 50
gratis gratis
bueno entonces el caso es que hay un
residente de la ciudad de melville en la
provincia de saskatchewan que quería
ponerle su apellido en su placa desde su
auto no sólo de que su apellido es
assmann
ss man0 es el trastero que adopta y
tiene muchos nombres en distintos
lugares de américa el trasero para aquí
decentemente lo podemos llamar el
trasero y mal hombre no entonces el
hombre trasero
o el hombre del trasero o el trasero del
hombre o qué sé yo entonces
la resuelta que la sociedad de que emite
las placas allá en saskatchewan le dijo
que esa inscripción era demasiado vulgar
y depresiva así ofreció entonces que no
se la podía dar el en su defensa dice
que el que no tiene ninguno
ninguna vergüenza por su apoyo porque y
además de eso y dice es que en alemán
porque es de ascendencia alemana él dice
que no se pronuncia assmann si no os -
por ese camino no me causa ningún
problema eso pero en la la compañía la
oficina dijo que aunque se produce de la
forma que se quiera pronunciar o sea no
no no no funciona y que no se le puede
personalizar su auto en su apellido
igual el medio no poco en el mío por
ejemplo elige menos
gimeno ahora sabe que a medida que vas
contando la historia se me está
ocurriendo a mí que estoy buen señor
bien podría demandar a la oficina de
alquilar absolutamente porque está
usando nombre y mirá acá dice que en
1995 el mismo nombre había suscitado
mucho entusiasmo bautizado a semenya
las manías o qué sé yo por mayoría del
trasero y si la manía de traseros no se
desconocen acá los que nos están
escuchando ese programa de televisión en
la televisión estadounidense presentado
por david letterman
letterman show de hecho si entonces él
ahí
había entrevistado a un empleado de la
estación de una estación desde la misma
provincia de saskatchewan
y a eso lo llamaron a semenya ellos allá
entonces porque este tipo se llamaba de
assmann
también explicado entonces no lo
expliquemos pero dejemos la imaginario
que es la manera digamos obscena de
decir o una de las tantas manera obscena
de decir el centro masculino lo que no
entiendo es como un papá o una mamá se
le puede ocurrir así ya sabemos pues que
es el diminutivo de richard exacto hay
que decirlo no los tics son richard el
verdadero nombre es richard entonces qué
le dicen tics como a los leonardos le
dice leo no como a los pedros dicen pp
francisco le dicen pacholí funk punk o
un ábaco
[Risas]
vamos vamos vamos a hacer franco el
problema surge aquí porque la idea que
te debe surgir este señor a los
empleados de la oficina y al público en
general cuando en esta patente no es
precisamente una denominación tan
delante como el señor del trasero es el
señor de los anillos pero del trasero
nombre podríamos hablar pero no no no
estamos opinando fuera del recipiente
por ahí tengo un mensaje de miriam
urbina que dice que comenta el reportaje
algo raro está sucediendo con el campo
magnético de la tierra
hola me gustaría ver información más
reciente sobre este tema este tema las
últimas investigaciones y me imagino que
el reportaje como tal es justamente las
nuevas investigaciones en relación con
el campo magnético de la tierra entonces
supongo que ahí va a encontrar más
información así que gracias a miriam la
gente que sigue conectando en este caso
andrés satán dice saludos desde la
asunción
andrew porque estamos para que se vaya
acostumbrando a su nombre en español así
es andrea y andrés están emilio mariño
alena
sr
saludos muy bien y leonardo allí tengo
un comentario sobre familia colombiana
evita deportación a último momento y se
m y se me dice dios es bueno y le van a
conceder su estadía definitiva en este
maravilloso país ya yo le quería
recordar a las personas que nos están
escuchando con respecto a esta historia
de las placas como como es la cómo
funciona lo de las placas allá en sus
países no sé a qué opinan qué opinan que
nos den su opinión no sobre lo que
hablamos de con lo que acabamos de
conversar personas personales o no
sí exacto si son simplemente p la placa
normal
louis
señor luis laborda muchas horas estimado
aquí tengo mensaje que nos envía a manda
cabrera a narváez sobre el tema tienen
grupos sanguíneos los animales y ella
pregunta o ella dice mejor dicho por
favor necesito saber la diferencia entre
un cruce de mendel y un cruce r h help
me please yo bueno yo creo que yo no sé
por mi parte personalmente no puedo
ayudarla porque sobre todo el grupo de
méndez no sabemos quiénes son de la
música de mendelssohn pero no un grupo
de mandalas - entonces habrá que
investigar veces así de simple
y la respuesta exacta pero vamos a
investigar a ver qué se le puede agregar
a ese comentario marque la ley que hay
que buscar la respuesta sí sí sí que
tenemos no sé si nos está escuchando en
este momento pero bueno ahí le quedamos
en deuda como se llama al final hoy se
llama amanda cabrera narvay que llamando
entonces te prometemos que vamos a
regresar con el tema y un poco más de
información contenido y giovanni cortes
duran dice buenas tardes estoy muy
interesado en hacer parte de la policía
montada porque hay una convocando la
policía montada de canadá abre sus
puertas a los inmigrantes un tema que
nosotros abordamos allí en radio canadá
internacional y ha habido ha sido muy
popular además está el ejército también
que está abriéndose para extranjeros
para los inmigrantes de origen
extranjero
en el caso del ejército son los
residentes no tienes que ser ciudadano
ya para tener para poder aplicar
acaso giovanni dice estoy muy interesado
en hacer parte de la policía montada soy
ingeniero agrónomo y tengo 47 años de
edad practico deporte si me encuentro en
excelente forma física estaré dentro de
los parámetros de la selección se
pregunta él
no sé dónde vive
giovanni para que viva aquí ya estar
viviendo aquí en canadá o ser ciudadano
o residente canadiense porque se habla
en realidad podría pero no pasa es que
va a tardar más porque el proceso de
inmigración también es bastante largo no
digamos tedioso pero más online más o
menos entonces no y la policía no va a
convocar a alguien que vive en el
exterior para que se sume sus frases
para gente que ya está en el territorio
si ese es el caso puede poner en google
crc mp que son las siglas de la real
policía montada canadiense le va a
parecer el sitio internet de la policía
y allí va a encontrar toda la
información
en el índice gracias por los saludos
cuba dice emilio gustavo lucas
de melo en uruguay y javier gonzález
lugares en méxico no se personalizan las
placas de los carros que algunos las
modifican pero causan infracciones bueno
muy bien en méxico méxico seguimos
esperando más comentarios a este
respecto pero mientras tanto vamos a
abordar los temas que queremos resaltar
porque el tiempo pasa muy rápido
entonces que la que ustedes que
representan a ver paloma de tú tú me
decías que qué temas vas a tocar tú hoy
a la policía fronteriza de canadá está
acusada de acoso y agresión sexual como
jesús pues resulta pablo que la red
inglesa de radio canadá si vice news
hizo una solicitud de acceso a la
información porque había recibido
algunos mensajes de gente del público
diciendo que varias denuncias se habían
presentado ante la policía fronteriza de
canadá por casos de acoso y de agresión
sexual y además de utilización
inadecuada de
fuerza en ciertas en ciertos casos de
deportación particularmente entonces si
vice se puso a investigar en su
investigación logró obtener información
directamente de la policía en las que ex
ss con css se sabe pues que en una
investigación en relación a 1.200
denuncias cree exactamente quejas del
público en contra de la policía
fronteriza canadiense y la propia
policía está investigando sobre sus
propios empleados entonces no hay una
instancia independiente haciendo la
investigación normalmente lo que se hace
es que es otro cuerpo de policía el que
hace ese tipo de investigaciones acá en
el caso de estas 1.200 denuncias es la
de la policía fronteriza canadiense que
está investigando sus propios sobres sus
propios empleados y se trata de quejas
en 3030 2016 y 2018 ahora bien entre los
documentos obtenidos por la civil
de los delitos que se están investigando
son asociación criminal por parte de
agentes de la policía fronteriza
canadiense fuerza excesiva uso del
lenguaje sexual inapropiado entonces hay
varias hay muchos casos que están siendo
tratados ahora el año pasado nosotros
presentamos el caso de lucy granados una
guatemalteca para la cual existió mucho
movimiento de solidaridad por los grupos
de la sociedad civil que se presentaron
a su favor ella fue deportada en el 2018
pero llegó a canadá en el 2009
solicitando el refugio político el 2018
el gobierno de canadá es decir la
policía fronteriza de canadá se presentó
a su casa temprano en la mañana eso es
lo que ella dice que sucedió sino que se
presentó en su a su casa en la mañana y
fue sacada por la fuerza fue herida
lesionada por los agentes de seguridad
de la policía fronteriza canadiense
de la acción exactamente y fue deportada
sivigila contacto y resulta ser que
existen informes médicos que indican que
esa lesión que sufrió con por la fuerza
utilizada por las fuerzas canadienses
sigue siendo un algo que la que la moler
que la afecta en su vida cotidiana hoy
ya en guatemala no tiene un año allá con
esa lesión y no pueda ser útil el uso de
su brazo de la misma manera que lo hacía
antes de hecho lo tienen realmente sin
movilizan y si moverlo mucho entonces
tenemos en este reportaje que les
presento yo está en la entrevista que se
que hizo si vice news en español con luz
y granados y bueno todo el licor
exactamente y todo el contexto de esta
investigación alrededor de los delitos
que habrían sido hechos por los agentes
de vida de la policía fronteriza
canadienses porque eso suele suceder
suele suceder que
que ellos que la policía en general no
cuando va a detener a alguien o en estos
casos de expulsión cuando la gente se
resiste que pueden aplicar una fuerza
exagerada no y bueno y que seas hombre o
que seas mujer poco importa ya el
tratamiento es el mismo yo me acuerdo la
última vez que pasé en auto hacia eeuu
la gente france fronterizo
estadounidense me pregunta por preguntas
hacen preguntas de rigor
de dónde viene a dónde va cuánto tiempo
va a estar y qué profesión tiene yo dije
soy periodista trabajó en radio canadá y
me preguntó ustedes son los que escriben
cosas de los agentes
[Risas]
ahora sí nunca entendí por qué cuando
vas a atravesar la frontera te preguntan
no en todos los casos pero casi siempre
la profesión que de la problemas y
aparte es como si uno hiciera y si era
abuso de manos 12 periodistas de acuerdo
con lo que hace poco puedo no en
realidad no me lo dije porque me
preguntaron
paloma eso fue todo si solamente decir
que el portavoz de la agencia de
servicios fronterizos de canadá
justamente respondió
a veces es necesario utilizar la fuerza
bueno yo no creo personalmente no
aparece mi humilde opinión que sea
necesario utilizar la fuerza pero where
yo conozco un joven policía que trabaja
en la policía de laval que vemos tenemos
charlado y hay veces que sí es necesario
necesario porque la gente que está al
otro lado actúa de manera que si yo no
actuó con fuerza el lesionado es el
policía entonces yo supongo que él debe
hacer referencia a ese tipo de cosas
cuando se pone violenta la situación a
partir de la persona que está siendo
indagada entonces
la manera yo creo que deben tratar de
justificar lo de esa manera pero igual
sería preferible no siempre hubiera que
no hubiera fuerza y que la investigación
sea imparcial de sant o sea que es el
mismo cuerpo de policía que investiga
los policías que se acusa de estos
hechos luis laborda perdón señor muy
bien la gorda
el gobierno federal canadiense permitirá
que los venezolanos que se encuentran
sin estatus legal en canadá puedan
permanecer en el país sí señor todos
conocemos por lo que se viene hablando
de hace ya varias semanas la situación
política en venezuela es complicada es
un país virtualmente con dos presidentes
uno que ha sido elegido en elecciones
producidas en mayo del año pasado y otro
nombrado o autoproclamado o auto
nombrado o nominado por la asamblea que
él presidía y que ha logrado el apoyo de
varios países en alrededor de 40 países
se salvan apoyar a ellas canadá y hay
venezolanos que viven aquí en canadá
pero que no tienen un estatus permanente
es decir no tienen su situación
definitivamente resuelta entonces lo que
hace el gobierno lo que viene de hacer
el gobierno canadiense desarrollaron
algo sí sí sí es una decisión que acaba
de ser adoptada es dada la situación
allí en venezuela a esta gente le ha
otorgado una moratoria por la cual
aquellos que no tienen un estatuto
permanente no corren riesgo
transitoriamente de ser expulsados del
país esto involucra no solamente a
quiénes no
en su situación totalmente definida sino
por ejemplo también a trabajadores
temporales que puede ser que haya
iniciado un proceso para lograr la
permanencia en canadá y que en el
ínterin su contrato haya vencido muy
incluso a estudiantes que están prontos
a terminar sus estudios o que habiendo
los ya terminados a iniciar un proceso
para lograr la residencia permanente y
tal vez
posteriormente postular a la ciudadanía
pero que ese trámite
sabemos todos tarda un tiempo en avanzar
entonces toda esa gente del gobierno de
dicta esta moratoria que por un plazo de
a- de terminar no se sabe aún todavía
les va a permitir permanecer aquí o por
lo menos no correr el riesgo de ser
expulsados y la duda es qué pasaría si
esa situación en venezuela se resuelve
en el corto plazo bueno esa moratoria
expira automáticamente es decir no es
una carta blanca para permanecer en el
país y por supuesto tampoco es una carta
blanca para aquellos que tienen
causas pendientes por algún delito o por
alguna violación de derechos humanos o
por algún crimen cometido esa gente no
puede postularse no puede aspirar a los
beneficios de esta moratoria bajo ningún
concepto los invito entonces se
escucharon en alegran que le vi
colaborando con una abogada especialista
en temas de inmigración que es claudia
molina lista tu entrevista en una hora
laborda es rapidísimo leonardo gimeno
hay otros comentarios
en este caso gustavo luca se nos dice
muy interesante el contenido del
programa acá en uruguay creo que no es
posible personalizar las placas de los
automóviles de todos modos estos
automóviles que llevan placas con
motivos decorativos por ejemplo pero
siempre llevando la placa específica del
departamento correspondiente se aclaró
que el departamento son las
circunscripciones administrativas que
dividen uruguay lo que en los países son
provincias
y las placas las ponemos en la parte
delantera o en la parte trasera aquí es
obligatorio que sea en la parte de atrás
eso lo que es
y yo creo que todo el mundo en los dos
lados y yo no entiendo por qué la
policía te detiene ya de una vez se
tiene
leonardo aparte del ahorro de recursos
tú nos hablas de un programa de google
que advierte las y las contraseñas
fueron violadas
así es en realidad bueno hay uno de los
de los temores
más presentes de la sociedad
digitalizada de hoy en día cuántas
cuentas tienen ustedes tienen 345
cuentas de correo electrónico encontré
cuentas bancarias tienen cuentas de todo
y en todos tienen un usuario un password
y lo más probable es que ese password se
repita bastante
aunque sea utilice para diferentes el
mismo password para como es casi mi caso
1 2 3 4 5 6 pero 1 2 3 4 5 6 y password
la palabra son los pasos más utilizados
en el mundo hay gente que todavía usa
eso
lo que hay que hacer en realidad la
recomendación particular es que cada
cuenta tenga un único una única
contraseña para evitar el robo nos
llenamos la huella digital no no no no
tanto como es para una cuenta en ordenar
el dedo pero tienen que entrar y cambiar
y cambiarlos si se enteran que hubo
algún tipo de violación de privacidad
entonces ir a cambiar el para la casa se
cambia cada tres meses exactos en este
caso el alemán password sicab
qué es lo que está presentando jun
google es una pequeña es un pequeño
programa que funciona dentro del google
chrome del navegador de google también y
que cuando uno llena el password para
entrar a la cuenta de correo electrónico
a la cuenta bancaria ellos chequean con
una base de datos inmensa que se ha ido
generando a partir de este tipo de venta
a base de pan y un red de hace hacen una
búsqueda para ver si ha sido o no
comprometido alguna vez entonces uno
tiene esto abierto en el navegador
cuando uno entra el navegador le le dice
a uno le avisa está esta contracción
está comprometida por favor cambia así
que bueno esos son los pros los contras
son que la gente que habla de privacidad
dice que si google ahora tiene la manera
de ver nuestras contraseñas es con un
poquito
[Música]
usa un password también no es gratis
pero ellos
explican que no y aído la explicación
técnica en él
que no necesariamente sino que hacen
como una especie de chequeo y vuelve y
no queda en los servidores entonces es
imposible que ellos guardan la
información que les creo yo en realidad
yo lo instalé para probarlo lo que voy a
hacer va a ser chequearlo durante un mes
o mes y medio puede sacarlos si no lo
necesitan
el resultado de las recomendaciones
están ahí así que ok entonces bueno hay
que decirle que aquí en este trabajo en
el que nosotros estamos los passwords
las claves son hay un montón de claves
llegas a ver es tu computador necesitas
una clave después si quieres abrir los
otros programas con los que tienes que
trabajar cada programa tiene su clave
todos dicen que cambia nadie te dice
cómo hacer para recordar todas las
claves que te tienen que acordar y te
dicen que sobre todo que no hay que
escribirlas en ningún lado entonces pues
después hay un problema y bueno entonces
el tiempo pasa muy rápido bueno yo por
mi parte
y yo por mi parte pues rápidamente los
invito a escuchar una entrevista que
hice con el representante de juan guaidó
aquí en canadá
orlando viera blanco que justamente el
lunes de esta semana se llevó a cabo
aquí en la en canadá y en la ciudad de
ottawa en particular la décima reunión
ministerial de los del grupo de lima del
cual forma parte canadá y en ese en esa
reunión en la ceremonia de apertura de
esa reunión
canadá reconoció ya oficialmente a juan
guaidó como presidente interino de
venezuela y al mismo paso presentó a
orlando viera blanco y lo reconoció como
el representante oficial de guaitó aquí
en canadá
entonces conversamos con él pues para
para ver de qué como como ve él todo
este proceso la entrevista está en
nuestro sitio radio canadá internacional
puntos ya y bueno desafortunadamente ese
fue todo el tiempo
también hay una entrevista
dejuan white también hay un portal que
trabaja exactamente porque si vice
también entrevistó a juan guaidó en
caracas entonces tenemos una versión en
español con información y con contexto
con respecto a esta entrevista decís
juande
el próximo 13 de febrero dice javier la
unesco estableció el día mundial de la
radio
así que por tal motivo de felicitaciones
para radio canadá internacional
está cumpliendo año
64 nada más que los controles técnicos
sentarse en sober aquí en el estudio
luis la guarda paloma martínez y
leonardo gimeno
les recuerdo que en la versión audio de
este programa que estará en nuestro
internet y en podcast como me lo
recordaba mi querida paloma estará en
esa versión
vamos a escuchar la música de la joven
cantautora de montar a charlotte chart
no serlo cardan así que se están todos
invitados a escuchar una muy bonita voz
en esta chica bueno eso fue todo
gracias adiós adiós
[Música]